[Music]
you know what I'm gonna say it's time
once again to were ain't stop why the
heck is there another PS Plus video this
month well if you kept your eyes on III
2019 you know why the game we've
received this month Borderlands the
handsome collection has a free extra
downloadable now until July the 8th so
please don't miss out on getting this
for free the brand spanking new DLC is
named commander Lilith and the fight for
sanctuary what's great about this DLC is
that it will bridge the gap from the
story of Borderlands 2 to bottle and
three if you're a lover of story and the
progression of narrative this will be
massive news to you
why isn't Lilith the siren anymore and
what the hell happened to our home city
of sanctuary things happened in between
both games and this is where we
experienced that the official blurb says
the vault map has been stolen and a
toxic gas is poisoning Pandora with new
bosses new enemies new villains hell
bent on ruling the planet it's time to
kick chewing gum and eat ass
hang on home I think I said that wrong
anyway here with a new level cap of 80
new veterans have something to aim for
or if you quite new to it you can boost
up to level 30 instantly if you don't
want to finish the campaign first
Borderlands - commander Lilith and the
fight for sanctuary is a must play for
any Borderlands funds new or old so if
you have PS plus download it right now
for free on July 8th it'll cost real
money again anyway I'm going to play
right now I'm Adam from PlayStation
granade it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time
[Music]